son I look like a sperm bro straight up
I know that's why I've been thirsty how
white is Neil deGrasse Tyson what who
else gives a [ __ ] about space that much
more their middle name uh yeah that is
the corniest [ __ ] in the world deGrasse
oh he might be Drake's dead grass
Degrassi that's corny enough Andy's
white he loves white [ __ ] Raleigh got a
white wife what color's his wife white
no he's not married but he'd be out
there me too it me too in whom quite who
would snitch lying [ __ ] wrong and I
cannot fathom that black girls are
dealing with some corny [ __ ]
like that do you think black girls will
find a corny ass dude like that
attractive I can't imagine one literally
he's Carlton manifested yeah Carlton
Brad or Hughes character in the best
show forever
well can I at least had a little charm
without trying to he's just
condescending he that's all here he just
comes on and he's condescending and he's
done nothing like I looked it up he's
done nothing he's hasn't published [ __ ]
he's done nothing as a scientist I think
we're just like so excited that we could
not be racism black hair like a black
scientist I love that coat do you don't
think that's what the scientific
community did they're like hey this I'll
give him this he's incredibly good at
explaining complex [ __ ] in a simple way
the biggest problem with a lot of these
scientists is and you've probably
experienced this with like family
members yours they're like doctors and
yeah I know I I heard it I heard it you
never look at me to make sure her my
feelings you look like a doctor right
now
do any of your uncle's or aunts have the
ability to fit my nose in this Jesus I
can't even get excited because it comes
out I need a mask now you get excited in
okay
where are we saying Neil deGrasse Tyson
he's done nut goat the scientific
community propped him up because he's
black not because he's black he explains
difficult [ __ ] and that's what I was
saying about your fair measure I'm sure
you have a family member that's a doctor
that is really good at explaining
complex science [ __ ] and then one that's
not yes great and you probably go to the
one that's really good my person I give
him credit in this he's very good at
simplifying tricky science [ __ ] because
and I've watched some of these guys on
Rogan some guys are really good at it
and some guys just aren't mm-hmm they
just speak way above your head and
they're using terms that you don't
[ __ ] know about and you're like you
can't use a more complex term to explain
something than the thing you're
explaining right right he's very good at
that and he's black yeah
which helps it works yeah he's Jason
Williams what Jason Williams was too
basketball oh [ __ ] white chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate now Jason
Williams was undeniably one of the best
passers in the history of the game an
incredibly exciting player teammates
love to play with them and he was
incredibly engaging to watch and he was
also like there were guys that were
black that were passing the ball behind
their back he's not the first person to
do it Earl the Pearl Monroe was doing
that [ __ ] Yeah right so it's like tons
of people have been doing it but he did
it he was the most different meaning he
was this white player who did not play
traditionally in a white game granted
Pistol Pete did all that kind of stuff
and was white but you understand offense
in Spence epistle you didn't have
anybody like nothing like that there was
white yeah right so I be early John
Stockton a bunch of fundamental ass guys
running screen and rolls mm-hmm and then
here goes Jason Williams playing this
exciting brand of basketball that we'd
normally associated with black people
and he looks the exact opposite of those
black people boom so you're just like
holy [ __ ] this is the guy Eminem Eminem
now Eminem again everybody is gonna do a
little something extra they're gonna be
really good at what they do or tap into
a feeling that black rappers couldn't
tap into for white people you know like
the intelligence of Eminem like hi kids
do you like violence that's the first
line to his first single that's
marketing
one very smart guy I mean think about
that first line if you're a young kid
angsty kid
yeah it wants to rebel yeah you know
living in America in wonderful times of
luxury right you're bored yeah and then
some white rapper guy comes down goes hi
kids do you like violence yeah you're
like I want to listen to everything else
this guy has to say and he's a white
dude talking about violent [ __ ] but he's
doing it in a medium that was normally
black people talking about violence he's
a different violent [ __ ] but hey look
this is different and he's good look at
that and let's be honest cool and
blackness go together I mean they really
do that cool and blackness they have
there is synergy right black culture
often defines cool yes right like when
white people were wearing [ __ ] pink
shirts and salmon colored shorts and
[ __ ] like that it wasn't cool
Kanye starts wearing it now it's cool
right right why people wearing [ __ ]
raggedy shirts and all that kind of
stuff it wasn't cool Kanye start to put
it well dorkiest thing in the world
until 2018 was a fanny pack now all the
sudden is cool it's cool so black people
make [ __ ] cool so if I'm the scientific
community I'm like you know give me a
black guy to explain this side [ __ ] if
we need to trick kids into being
scientists because we're gonna lose the
intellectual race like if we're talking
on nation craft you know I'm saying
we're gonna trick kids into being
scientists you know the stupid
commercials they put out where they're
like it was it's so important to be a
scientist it's so important
mathematician that [ __ ] don't work you
know it works if you make it cool yeah
right so how do I make it cool now this
is typical white executive way of doing
[ __ ] which is well just make a black
person do it that'll be cool yeah you
know what they forgot
Neil deGrasse sizes a [ __ ] dork
nobody's doing anything because Neil
deGrasse Tyson said so I have yet to
meet a person that says that's my hero
is that a picture of Neil deGrasse Tyson
so this is young Neil deGrasse Young he
fell off yo young Neil deGrasse was a
bad [ __ ]
he fell off damn line I mean he was
swole he was sweaty he was on that yak
yeah probably though it is now go to the
picture of him and his wife hmm
you look cool the [ __ ] you got with this
[ __ ] now look Adam in the infinite
universe that was the one look at his
[ __ ] vest and tie combo on this way
all of it just he looks like a boat act
this is what a fall off dude well this
is one of the most historic fall outs in
history so you guys saw a picture of
what Neel looked like when he was
younger college Neal with somewhat in
chops bra swole how your body body
Lindsay oh now understand why he's
meeting these girls you know you
probably never had to ask for [ __ ]
until just now see it never hide you
probably get less [ __ ] and now you're
famous that's how hard he fell off
that's how hard he fell loved us how
nerd out he got man now he's sitting
there wearing [ __ ] van Gogh painting
vests
[Music]